Animal crackers on the Tuesday and blog
29.
Ah,
so when we look at a map of the world,
we see countries,
countries divided up by very neatly
drawn lines,
lines which have a nice sense of
finality to them,
right?
This land belongs to this country and
that land on the other side of this line
belongs to that one.
Of course,
we know that the geopolitical reality is
anything but as conclusive as these
lines suggest.
We know that there is civil fighting,
contestations of land and ownership,
local loyalties,
local hatreds,
religion,
sex and factions who can and often do
flip their noses at straight lines drawn
in comfy rooms by foreigners.
At some time in the past,
we've come to use and our global
parlance,
the word nation state to identify these
places.
It's a term we don't think too much
about.
We use it freely without going to our
dictionaries,
but the truth is,
of course that nation state as a term
quite often fails to adequately describe
many of these countries where,
for example,
civil war is a continuing reality.
So maybe by pulling the term apart,
we can get a better understanding of how
these two words,
nation and state can come together.
Now the state is what can be defined by
lines on a map.
The area over which the state central
power called the sovereign has
controlled the sovereign in theory,
has a monopoly on all the violence that
occurs in the state and on the
international stage.
The sovereigns voice in theory is an
equal among other saffrons.
This is the basic definition of
sovereignty,
equal abroad master at home.
It was John Bowden and the 16th century
who first laid out these characteristics
in his six books of the Commonwealth.
Thereafter,
Beaudin and others having worked at it's
used,
try to figure out where the source of
sovereignty light,
but and believed as was the custom of
his time,
that the sovereign then ruled by a king
or prince was derived from God and
political thinkers for the next two
centuries continue to find the source of
sovereignty and divine right or in the
laws of nature or social contracts.
But by the end of the 18th century,
a revolutionary new idea came to the
fore.
It said that the source of sovereignty
lay not in the man upstairs,
but in the many men and later women
downstairs.
In other words,
the source of sovereignty was in the
people.
You see it loud and clear.
In the very first line of the
declaration of independence,
when in the course of human events,
it becomes necessary for one people to
dissolve the political bands,
etc.
Etc.
OnE people.
In other words,
one nation.
By this time the word nation had become
synonymous with the word people.
So here you have a state which finds the
justification for its sovereign power,
the monopoly on all the violence that
happens within its borders,
in the consent of the people,
the nation,
hence nation state.
The questiOn becomes,
how do you define a people?
What makes people a people?
We have a number of problematic nation
states in the world,
places couched in what seems like
unceasing violence,
and to understand them,
we must first understand how people
develop a national identity.
Now,
there are a number of thIngs that groups
can share.
A language race or religion,
but stronger than all of these is as
John Stuart mill,
the great liberal thinker said,
and identity of political antecedents,
a possession of a national history,
a community of recollections,
collective pride and humiliation,
pleasure and regret connected with the
same incidents in the past.
A historical narrative,
a national memory.
This binds people closer together than
any other common trait.
Unfortunately,
and as we know too well,
the many millions of people who find
themselves in a state very often don't
have the same memory.
Narratives diverged or rewritten mixed
with myth and fiction as the years and
decades pile on.
All of a sudden you have one state with
two people or three peoples,
and the proBlem grows.
It took 400 years and a lot of blood for
the island of Ireland to resolve issues
between nation and state.
Wasn't easy.
Catholic,
irish and protestant irish have very
different memories of a national history
full of conquest and subjugation.
In 1921,
the largely catholic southern part of
the island declared itself independent
from britain.
the protestants being largely of british
descent and who held power in the north
had no desire to break from the uk,
so a partition was built separating the
irish free state from north Ireland.
Good solution,
right?
Keep the warring factions apart.
The only problem is that the catholic
still in north Ireland became an ill
treated minority.
Here's a map showing the distribution of
catholics and protestants in northern
Ireland doesn't really suit straight
lines on a map,
does it?
Fortunately in 2007,
the irish troubles were settled
peacefully.
However,
this kind of conclusion isn't really the
norm,
though there is a partition,
for example,
on the island of Cyprus,
the northern turkish cypriots and the
southern greek cypriots haven't yet come
to the same conclusion because the
issues of nation and state there haven't
yet been resolved,
nor have they been resolved for kurdish
muslims,
the largest single group of people in
the world who don't have a state of
their own.
Now we know of course that many kurds
live in the northern part of Iraq,
but few,
if any,
identify themselves as iraqi.
The example that we're perhaps most
familiar with is that of Israel and
palestine.
We know the hiStory and we know how each
party writes the narrative and who's to
say which is right.
Just last saturday was landed and annual
day of palestinian protest for an event
in 1976 in which the israeli government
plan to expropriate thousands of
palestinian demands for security and
settlement purposes.
One protester was killed,
more,
were injured and sent to hospitals.
What are the remedies when you have to
peoples living in a territory to which
both can lay claim territories which are
part of their history,
their family history.
Well,
you can have external forces come in and
try to referee the situation,
but we've seen from firsthand experience
how imperfect such illusions can be.
How about partitions like in Ireland or
Cyprus?
Difficulty is.
There's always gonna be people on both
sides.
We think the partition is unfair.
What about population movement?
It kind of ethnic cleansing where one
people has to move to another place.
It's a solution,
but an extremely painful one,
which who are forced to move,
lose everything.
All of these remedies are not lightly
taken,
but the sad truth is that they are often
better than the alternative,
which is endemic violence that feeds on
itself.
Lessons here are feeble,
but maybe this is the most important
one.
Violence of this kind produces precisely
those experiences which pass into
history,
confirming,
strengthening the identity of both
sides.
Worse violence of this kind produces
people with a stake in it.
Continuing,
namely young men to whom such civil war
becomes a way of life,
providing a source of employment,
excitement,
adventure,
and most importantly,
purpose.
Sovereignty is a problematic thing.
It can often produce deeply depressing
results,
but if there's one thing that we can do
as an international community,
it's to try to understand the history
and example of such cases to try to
foresee and prevent new antagonisms
before the violence that consumes them
becomes a self generating monster.
Well,
you actually mentioned the manage to
keep most of them in.